the uk government said it was surprised
the eu was enforcing the protocol those
checks in the rsc
as emphatically as it is does that
surprise you
um well it does in a sense that i think
the the uk government there aren't any
illusions about where the eu is coming
from in relation to the protocol but the
european union is willing and
very engaged in endeavoring to find a
resolution to the issues that have been
raised
uh in respect of the the northern
ireland ireland protocol
and in my view the channels do exist to
get this resolved
and in particular the seskevich frost
process should be fully explored
and optimized to get an agreement and i
think uh the prospects in my view
if there's a will there on both sides
and there is a will there for the
european union side i know that
i detect from the british prime minister
boris johnson british government is
anxious to get a resolution of this
uh so i think we should we should work
at it that's more hopeful than we've
heard for quite a while there's still a
lot of
points scoring going on over brexit so
is there not a danger of the politics
thwarting attempts to find solutions i
think we need to move beyond where we
are
i think from my understanding of a lot
of the technical issues that have been
discussed progress can be made on quite
a lot of the issues
i believe the us administration's
comments
last week which were released
are interesting as well and so far as
they deal with a significant issue that
would concern the british government i.e
the capacity to do a trade deal with the
united states
whilst also having an sps
arrangement between the european union
and the united kingdom and in my view
there's a legitimate issue there for you
you know they can in government but in
our view an sps agreement would deal
with up to 80 percent of all of these
issues and i think it's a surprise what
uh
certainly exploring in the fullest
manner possible
to what extent do you understand the us
administration chastise the british
government
for the perceived threat at least to the
peace process
and do you believe president biden
perhaps has a further role to play in
help
helping to broker a solution i wouldn't
say it as a chastisement around
that i think the u.s president is very
clear on restoring the transatlantic
relationship between america and
the european union and america and the
united kingdom he sees
uk europe and the us aligned on the
fundamentals of
democracy freedom of speech that's very
important
and so he really wants the eu eu and the
uk to resolve this issue
he's also then of course as we know
absolutely committed to the good friday
agreement
the full working of the institutions of
the good friday agreement and he doesn't
want
discussions around the protocol uh to to
undermine the good friday agreement
and and he also wants to see full
engagement
and he believes there's a way and a root
as i do to getting these issues resolved
and i think
the big picture for him is to be fully
aligned
on the big issues of the day globally
between the eu america and the united
kingdom
and that really issues of this sort
should be should be
sorted you mentioned the good friday
agreement your government and indeed the
eu has repeatedly
argued that a border on the island of
ireland would pose a threat to the good
friday agreement
but with now thousands of loyalists
protesting at times on the street some
of them asked
does a border in the irish sea not pose
just as much of a threat to that
agreement well again i think
the the nature of brexit has been
challenging in that respect
okay in terms of the absence of a
customs union and that but in our view
an sps agreement could deal with a lot
of the issues around food
animal welfare and and and so on and
in my view given the challenges
given the necessity to reduce tensions
we've never seen the protocol as a
constitutional issue it doesn't in any
way
interfere with the constitutional status
of northern ireland that's defined and
articulated within the good fight
agreement we're very clear from the
irish government perspective on that
and but we do believe in seamless trade
on the island of ireland it makes sense
we believe in seamless trade
so far as we possibly can between the
united kingdom and northern ireland we
think northern ireland's economy can
develop over time
through its access to uk market
obviously but also
access to the european union market if
you look at the dairy industry for
example
i mean bill comes north south seamlessly
without any issues that's important for
us to farmers it's important for
for the industry both sides of the
border and the second a practical
trade that we want to encourage we do
acknowledge that issues have arisen
that are causing concern we believe
those issues can be dealt with
in the context of the discussions
between the european union and the
united kingdom and we're willing to play
a helpful role in that
time is not on your side now if there is
no deal by the first of july
and the british government unilaterally
for a third time extends the grace
period this time for chilled mates
to avoid this so-called sausage war what
way would you expect the eu to respond
to that i think it'll be very
problematic because it's not about
sausages per se
it really is about the fact that an
agreement had been entered into not too
long ago
signed off by the british government
with the european union the trade and
cooperation agreement
including the withdrawal agreement and
the protocol and that creates a
if just consistent unilateral deviation
from that agreement
that clearly undermines the broader
relationship between the european union
and the united kingdom uh which is in
nobody's interest
and therefore that's why the uk with the
eu have to work very hard now
in the coming weeks i know the european
union are anxious to resolve this
and want to resolve it but that they
need to see
a similar reciprocity from the from from
the uk side
so just to be clear you believe sps
agreement is neither solution
and would you be hopeful that because
president biden has assured the british
government
that that wouldn't prevent a trade deal
that they may now
consider that seriously i think it is a
significant part of the solution
i think they should consider it very
seriously and i think it could lead
um to a breakthrough on this just one
final question
i'm conscious that arlene foster is
preparing to formally resign as first
minister
of northern ireland how concerned are
you that her ousting as dup leader
could destabilize the power sharing
administration first of all i want to
thank arlene a warm tribute to her for
her commitment to public life and public
service
over so many years and particularly
laterally in our capacity as first
minister and leader to dup
i had a good relationship with arlene
over the years bought when i was
foreign affairs over a decade ago in the
context of the devolution of justice
and i wish arlene well now uh in terms
with her family in terms of
the next stage of our journey in life
and i've also met with edwin putz i had
a good meeting with him in dublin
last week and i believe that he is
committed to the institutions of the
good friday agreement
to uh fulfilling all of the obligations
on that
we all have collectively uh so my i
have a view that we can you know
safeguard the institutions
and progress the various sets of
relationships that are
encompassed by the good fight agreement
itself so i think
uh you know there have been many twists
and turns in terms of the peace process
in terms of politics
uh in northern ireland the island of
ireland and between britain and ireland
and it falls on those of us who are in
positions of influence and positions of
leadership
uh to engage with each other uh and to
work together to resolve
the challenges that come our way thank
you for your time you're very welcome
indeed thank you